we're in alta floresta state of mato
grosso in Brazil on a boat going up the
river with Giselle Giselle has been in
the Amazon before but it's new to her to
be a correspondent to be a reporter and
not just to be the subject of the story
but to be an explorer and ask questions
we're going towards a 800 year old tree
and this tree represents everything
about the rainforest the importance of
it preservation of it the carbon that it
holds and the threat I'm from Brazil I
grew up in a small little village in the
south of Brazil when I was a kid I
thought the rainforest is invincible
massive forest that is indestructible
and as I grew up the face would be sad
reality that that's not the case
how can anyone want to destroy this how
can they do it this is the place for the
most amazing biodiversity in the world
this is the costigan de parada this is
our nut and you can eat it and that tree
over there that's where it comes from
it's a giant taking care of this forest
before the Portuguese arrived in Brazil
these channels are watching the forest
and are witnessing how its forest is
being chopped down and nowadays they can
see unfortunately they cannot talk while
we can talk for them allowed my best to
speak for them
if a tree could talk right
imagine the knowledge of this tree I
mean I realize even though is so grand
and magical how fragile at the same time
it is I feel that it's my responsibility
to try to do everything I can you know
to protect it